professor claudia kemfert vom deutschen
institut für wirtschaftsforschung die
fachfrau für energie und umwelt ich
grüße sie ganz herzlich
guten morgen sagt sich so leicht wenn
wir wissen dass es in zukunft alles
teurer wird wird's oder für privat und
für wirtschaft ja so sieht es leider im
moment aus in der tat ist es so dass die
preise für fossile energien sehr stark
nach oben gehen das treibt die
heizkosten nach oben auch die
benzinpreise wir sind auf einem niveau
ähnlich wie wir es schon mal vor zehn
jahren waren und hatten damals schon
diskussionen dass wir uns verabschieden
müssen von der fossilen energie leider
ist das nicht in ausreichendem maße
geschehen so dass wir jetzt auch die
preise dafür zahlen müssen und die
kosten tragen müssen für eben eine
verschleppte energie welle das thema ist
nicht neu aber im moment ist es leider
so dass in der tat die kosten steigen da
sind auch diese signale aus der
wirtschaft die sind ja fast schon
beunruhigend also wenn salzgitter steuer
konzern sagt wir haben zehn mal höhere
gaspreise als sonst wissen wir der stadt
wird auch teurer wenn er beispielsweise
schon warnt vor hohen gaspreisen und
deswegen keine neukunden annehmen will
der zeit wo stehen wir denn da jetzt
eigentlich vor was stehen wir eigentlich
ja wir haben immer von einer solchen
möglichen situation der gewandte dass
eben diese sehr starke abhängigkeit von
fossilen erdgas auf solche konsequenzen
haben kann wir haben ja eben den
russischen präsidenten er gehört dort
gibt es geostrategische interessen die
werden auch ausgespielt wenn man mehr
liefern könnte wollte könnte man es ja
auch und das wird eben dich in dem
umfang getan so dass man hier auch ein
druck ausüben will auf die europäische
politik und die beste antwort eben da
drauf und das müssen wir auch schon sehr
lange ist dass wir uns umstellen müssten
auch weg von fossilem erdgas auch die
industrie und gerade die industrie wir
haben in der vergangenheit sehr starke
fossile also auf erdgas basierende kraft
wärme kopplungs anlagen gefördert haben
eine politik gefahren eben auch die sehr
stark auf fossiles erdgas setzt das
wissen wir geht er so auch aus
klimaschutzgründen
ich ewig so weiter und hätten auch schon
längst investieren müssen zum beispiel
in solarthermische anlagen große
wärmepumpen auch für die industrie all
diese techniken sind da und jetzt muss
man auch wirklich daraus konsequenzen
ziehen investieren eben in eine fossil
freie wirtschaft und die die zeichen
dafür sind ja jetzt auch ein deutlich
genug ja das geht aber nicht so schnell
das kriegen wir dieses jahr nicht
nächstes jahr nicht hin wahrscheinlich
die nächsten fünf jahre nicht so geübt
dass wir tatsächlich beispielsweise auch
mit wasserstoff-technologie das ganze
auffangen können oder mit windrädern und
mit solar jetzt sagt die eu-kommission
wir müssen da eventuell eingreifen ist
das möglich tatsächlich möglich oder ist
es nur quasi wir haben darüber geld raus
na ja die frage ist eben was wo wie
eingreifen also ich halte es für
sinnvoll dass europa sich hier
koordiniert für eine europäische gase
strategische gasreserve ähnlich wie man
es ja auch beim öl hat und sich da auch
besser abspricht das wäre eine
möglichkeit dass man dann auch mehr
puffer hat wenn solche geostrategischen
situation häufiger auftreten und europa
hat er ohnehin auf eine diversifikation
der gas bezüge schon angestrebt man hat
ja auch hier vorkehrungen getroffen
sodass ist das eine was den gasmarkt
betrifft auf der anderen seite sehr
natürlich recht im moment sind die
kosten sehr hoch dass man da auch
abhilfe schafft insbesondere auch für
niedrig einkommen zu beziehen wir
schlagen schon lange vor eine pro kopf
klima prämie aus den einnahmen der co2
bepreisung rückzuerstatten das würde
insbesondere niedrig einkommensbezieher
entlasten und parallel in der tat müssen
wir die investitionen anschieben für
eine emissionsfreie wirtschaft für mehr
energetische gebäudesanierung mehr
bahnverkehr mehr ladeinfrastruktur damit
wir auch perspektivisch wirklich dann
weg kommen ebenfalls solche passieren
energien ja wir haben ja gerade auch
schon mal den zuschauern gezeigt die
preissteigerungen die wir von einem aufs
andere ja in dieses jahr herein hatten
das ist ja schon beunruhigend jetzt ist
die frage wie ist ihre prognose wie geht
es jetzt weiter vor allen dingen nicht
nur in deutschland sondern auch in
europa in anderen ländern wie sie sind
wahrscheinlich auf einem relativ
niedrigen niveau noch was das betrifft
oder ja also wir haben eben im moment
viele nachholeffekte jetzt nach alkohol
die wirtschaft hat wieder angezogen es
gibt aber auch einige sonderfaktoren bei
der kohle in china ausgelöst durch die
energiekrise dort oder beim gas eben
durch russland da wird man sehen wie
sich das und wann sich das auch
entspannen kann dass man wenn man wie
russland wenn man dazu gehört wirklich
annimmt dass sich die situation
entspannt wenn außerdem zwei in betrieb
geht wäre ja auch etwas was dann
tatsächlich preis senken wird das will
der russische präsident ja auch so dass
das so passiert und die andere also
gerade beim ölpreis wird man sehen wie
sich die welt klage stabilisiert das ist
denke ich er temporär was diese hohen
preissprünge angeht wir haben
spekulationen auch im system das darf
man nicht verschweigen insofern ist da
sehr schwer zu sagen wie lange das jetzt
andauert ob es jetzt einige monate
betrifft oder noch weit ins nächste jahr
hinein das muss man wirklich abwarten
und drinnen dann jetzt jemand sagt um
gottes willen und dann auch noch diese
energiewende die uns so viel kosten wird
dieser grüne strom den wir demnächst
brauchen was erklären sie denjenigen die
sagen ich will doch nicht noch mehr
zahlen
die erneuerbaren energien wirken
preissenkend es muss man sehr deutlich
sagen eine fossile energien sind im
moment sehr teuer hätten wir mehr
erneuerbare energien hätten bis zu drei
stunden nicht gerade an der strombörse
nicht auch das energetische sanieren
hilft ja eben um heizkosten heizkosten
zu sparen und dann noch der einsatz von
ökostrom oder zur herstellung auch im
gebäudebereich oder in der industrie
hätten wir das alles schon da hätten wir
diese preissprünge aktuell nicht so fern
lohnen sich diese westi zonen und helfen
eben auch der gesamten volkswirtschaft
dass man so preissprünge tatsächlich
vermeidet also wir müssen alle tapfer
bleiben professor claudia kemfert ist es
auch danke schön für das gespräch